speaking of movies yes and Excel [ __ ] I
saw a movie tonight
yeah choice how stoned are you you very
not gonna be about it in the alley Barry
I went to see ghostbusters yeah you went
to the premiere ghosts buzz just
downtown at the promoter I shouldn't
miss nevermind lot of enthusiasm um it
was I enjoyed it man I know like you
know there's a big hubbub and whatnot
but those people are funny and they made
a funny movie you know the same people
that are unhappy about it now yeah
probably not going to change their mind
I'll win them over
you probably not but it's it's funny
it's not like you know I've heard like
trouble and [ __ ] like that
I laughed quite a few times but this is
the really [ __ ] sweet thing like is
crazy dude there were little kids in my
theater dancing dressed up like
ghostbusters and singing the song and
dancing and this is gets even more
tender they were little girls Wow so
you're sitting there gone like wow there
it is man the power of the flick and it
hadn't even started yet and she had I
don't know if they were dancing after
the movie but but before the movie was a
really really beautiful thing is a
kid-friendly is it something kids will
go my god you could take [ __ ] a
one-year-old - it's very kid-friendly
just like the original Ghostbusters very
kid-friendly um let me see
kate mckinnon I thought was awesome you
know who's [ __ ] awesome in it is Thor
I believe his Chris Hemsworth whatever
yeah it was not carrying a hammer he's
not for Kevin dude like that he's always
carrying a hammer eat alright AC oh my
God he's so funny in the movie they
should make him even funnier in those
[ __ ] Marvel movies like he's got a
gift for comedy and [ __ ] they should
play him like in this movie he's the
dumb blonde like and it's it's the
OneNote joke but like he [ __ ] pulls
the taffy on it he's feed maybe laugh
out loud quite a few times
[ __ ] Thor go figure man ah there no
yeah
got a Thunder man got a chuckles that's
what I said
so yeah he's really good everybody's
good like you know there's some
wonderful little cameos the all the
remaining ghostbusters show up and then
there's a little ass in the [ __ ]
grass no I'm like totally as they've
been everywhere and Linda I would this
is a little spoiler though so if you
don't want to hear this uh what's he
supposed to do Lana Lana even Harold
Ramis has a little bit of an appearance
there's a bust of somebody in the
background and it's Harold right now
Jonathan's really really sweet
um yeah ah to be a ghost that would be a
weird yeah yeah yeah let me get uhm but
yeah it's I guess it comes out this week
or something like uh I don't know Friday
Friday next right right here's the the I
kept you know before the movie begins
they've got all the social media
call-outs on the screen like if you're
gonna tweet the event here's the twitter
address and all that stuff and the
tagline for the movie is answer the call
because who you gonna call
give it right no that doesn't make sense
at all like I was sitting there going
like button who's calling like in the in
the movie there's no like somebody
[ __ ] caller there's no ghost phone or
anything they pick up no I mean there's
a telephone to be sure but or not I
don't know it just kind of made no sense
like who you're gonna call would have
made more sense cuz you're like oh yeah
oh you're gonna call ghostbusters but
answer the call just felt like like the
hindu version of ghostbusters you know
like that because the call instead of
who you're gonna call the english
translator Koosh rip off first yeah yeah
that I was a little baffled by the
tagline and also I have an of
ghostbusters I'm not going like you know
all [ __ ] as a fan they did this or
that room but as a fan I would have
preferred it if it tied into the other
one it is a complete standalone film so
the other Ghostbusters movie didn't have
to reboot it universe and it's not like
I'm like oh my [ __ ] Joel who's been
rebooted not at all but as a guy who
likes comics and I love [ __ ] there's I
have my own intro
connected movie universe to two of them
at this point [ __ ]
I would have preferred it if it was like
hey we got this from these guys and
[ __ ] whatever [ __ ] or at one point
I'd heard that Bill Murray was gonna
play a ghost of Peter Venkman and I was
like that would have been so [ __ ]
metal and [ __ ] that does not happen um
but the cameos are very very cool and
stuff but that's the only and it's not a
complaint I don't want people writing it
up like he [ __ ] hate it I just would
have preferred if it they tied the
movies to get that would for me that
would have been [ __ ] cool right uh
other than that though like totally fun
movie all right so you're saying go see
it or don't I'm gonna say and I mean I'm
gonna go see yours owned I'll put it
like this answer the call alright fair
enough just I don't know what I mean the
slogan if you're feeling the car it's
the call um but you know it was [ __ ]
when they had a big premiere at
Grauman's so they've shut down the
street and stuff right um and yeah it
was real pay an ass cuz I live like two
blocks up from there the good news is I
live two blocks up so I [ __ ] walk to
the premiere and [ __ ] like that but
normally like when they do premiere it's
like [ __ ] you gotta go all the way
around stuff they shut the whole street
down the carpet was like so long too
like in the red carpet thing you walked
through what felt like a Ghostbusters
building had a giant Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man there and stuff so as
I'm going in um you know uh I was there
with Harley with my daughter and Jen my
wife went and Harley Harley gets home
like she's a you know she's [ __ ] 17
right and so if somebody takes her
picture at her premiere she's smart
enough to be like where is it online and
she knows where to find it and just
before I came here she called up to our
room she's like oh jesus [ __ ] christ
because I took pictures with Harley she
curses a lot I don't know where she gets
it at all but so again I'll tell ya
mouth without me and her on the red
carpet like Jen didn't want to jump into
the pictures and stuff so it was just me
and Harley in most of the pictures and
so I guess some website put the pictures
up of us and it's like Kevin Smith and
his wife
so she's like oh they think we're dating
I could do so much better
she's humiliated by but but anyway while
I was on the carpet
this was kind of [ __ ] cool my inner
12 year old was just like um I'm sorry
what happened to your inner
twelve-year-old spontaneously come oh
that happened to you when you were 12 a
lot yeah all the time until I figured
out how to master it to answer the call
no no but now it needs masturbating to
me um dan Aykroyd was there oh no way
yes and what am I here oh are you giving
me to like and he [ __ ] like you two
need to be in a movie
you should play like Dan Aykroyd son
well stalker I'm not sure which but like
you could totally pull that off yeah
people have said that in the past hey
yeah when there's a resemblance
so not that I'm a stalker that there's a
resemblance so he he you know I'm I'm a
huge blues brothers fair and going back
and of course Ghostbusters fan I used to
do the Blues Brothers with my friend
Ernie O'Donnell like in high school in
the talent shows and so so somebody was
like jumping take a picture of them and
normally I'm like no no no but I was a
gas and took a picture with Dan Aykroyd
in and I'm telling you like my [ __ ]
inner tween was like [ __ ] bucket last
and [ __ ] like I got out would it was
awesome it was really good I got wood I
got L know you got Elwood
all right well wood blues I understand
now all right you're just a second ago
like I'm a big Dan Aykroyd Fanny like
I'm Blues Brothers I'm unfamiliar with
them I thought you said I got wood
initially I thought you pitched a tent
because you saw that I thought you could
work both ways
Elwood got Elwood I got a little pound
on words I know it's not an impression
so you didn't understand this [ __ ] like
that but let me see maybe you'll
understand it better if I do it like
this
whoa uh
Elwood who uh happy anniversary
welcome to the final Hollywood babble-on
everyone I hope you enjoy the 250
episodes that we did dick hey man it's
me Kevin Smith thanks for watching do me
a favor click that thing below that says
subscribe every time you click that you
save a baby kitten from murder